in the last two months tens of thousands
of Americans have died from the corona
virus and because of how contagious it
is some families have suffered multiple
losses throughout this crisis we're
sharing the stories behind the numbers
our lead national correspondent David
Begnaud joins us from his home in New
York David good morning Anthony good
morning we're gonna take you to
Louisiana and Michigan both have some of
the highest death rates when it comes to
the virus and minority communities in
those states have been hit particularly
hard as they have elsewhere around the
country take Michigan for example
African Americans account for 14% of the
population but they're 41 percent of the
people who are dying from the virus so
we'll start in Detroit you're about to
meet a lady who says she lost her mother
her grandmother and her aunt March 26
was really kind of the day that you know
changed everything
Biba Addams didn't know it yet but on
that day she would say goodbye to two
generations of her family Hospital and
of course that would be the last day
that I would see them all her mother and
her grandmother Elaine and many head
live together in Detroit they worshiped
together at the same church and they
died in the same hospital just two weeks
apart
and that is her mom 70 year-old Elaine
she sang in the church choir she was a
retired school counselor 89 year old
many was the church mother as they
called her losing them all at once was
really overwhelming I'm thinking about
what holidays now what so much of my
historical legacy is lost to South
Louisiana no Kirsten Duffy lost her
husband personality he sure did
at six-foot-seven Keenan Duffy was the
life of the party it was earlier this
month the father of two from Lafayette
Louisiana took his mother to the
hospital she tested positive for the
corona virus and about a week later he
wound up in the same hospital did she
know he was in the hospital she didn't
want to tell her you know he was in the
hospital because he was still trying to
get her to recover Kirsten says Keenan
kept fighting a fever he said another
night last night Keenan Duffy died on
April 14th he would have turned 40 this
year he leaves behind his wife a
stepdaughter and his 11 year old son
Kaden's dad Keenan had been at the
grocery store after he dropped his
mother off at the hospital so there's no
way to say for sure where he may have
contracted the virus I will tell you
Keenan's mother miss zhuo name is Joanne
he's home she's recovering she has
survived and she is getting better at
her home in south Louisiana Gill well
it's nice to hear the good news of that
David but this is the thing that's why I
think it's so important to tell these
stories because so often numbers and
statistics don't hit home but when you
can put a name and a face and see how
these people were loved it really makes
a difference and you brought that out
when you hear the stories of both of
those families more than 50,000 people
gaile around the country and these are
just for families and we're gonna keep
telling them every morning if families
are willing to tell us those stories
it's important for us to hear and
families want their loved ones
remembered thank you David